hey everyone welcome to this motion
science Workshop about grunge typography
my name is Ryan and today we're going to
take a look at how I built some of the
textures for the grunge texture pack and
specifically how I took black and white
typography put some effects over top
built a rig and then animated all of the
effects through that rig so I could
build this animation out quickly and
easily it's super fun I can't wait to
show you let's get started
[Music]
all right so here we are in After
Effects and to begin what I want to
discuss is just the look of this and
what we're going to be building and then
what we're going to be getting into with
some of the animation ahead so this is
our look that we're going to be building
today it's a grunge look
um a little bit of blurriness we're
gonna distort these frames as much as
possible
this is a little intensive on your your
system so it's not something that you
can easily just kind of maneuver from
one to the other
um
so what I want to do in the second part
is show you how I set up this rig and
was able to create
this animation based upon the same
technique and the same look
and it was a little bit easier on my
system so I want to show both ways and
that way it gives you a good
understanding of how to create this
foreign
so a fun little
typography animation there's stuff
moving popping sliding
and the grunge texture pack is being
influenced with some of the beginning
Parts here and this bar that comes in
again right here
and then also the textures in the
background so
we're going to be doing a lot of grunge
today so let's start laying out a design
alright so I'm actually here in
illustrator and I want to show the
actual file and how I kind of built this
and some easy ways to work between
illustrator and after effects now you
can do this in After Effects I just like
to show my workflow to give you as many
options as possible and whatever makes
sense to you sometimes I like working
this way in illustrator because you can
lay out artboards and see your entire
design
in one shot and that's what this ended
up being so here's my 24 frames they all
can be laid out I can see one frame to
the next to the next and it just helps
me visualize the whole timeline in the
whole sequence so to do that in
illustrator
let's go to file new
set up my artboard which is going to be
a 4K comp so
3840-2160 let's do
four artboards that's fine RGB color
screen of 72 pixels per inch
click create and you can see that I have
four artboards now in the center of my
canvas
and everything is ready to rock and roll
if you go up here to Windows and then
artboard you can also get this window
here and this is where you can add
artboards if you want and then also
click this button and you can rearrange
all of them so say you want four columns
two columns set your spacing set your
layout order click OK and it's going to
rearrange them very quickly for you I
want to go back to three and there you
go and I can continually add and then
the minute you jump out it'll read
through that so just reset go to three
back to normal okay let's go back to
three and what I did
it t for the type tool typed out hey
[Music]
scaled it up as big as I could
too big
something like that centered it aligned
it to the center and then used a font
called din so this is Den 1451 standard
ink shrift there is a ton of dins
available I believe this one is
available online for free it's one of my
favorite dins
and I love using it so you can see here
this is
I did introduce the one that we're going
to be doing today is chaos so that is a
Hoffler text
and
let's make this big
and then align it and align it and
select it and then go to
and huffler text black
and that's set to Optical tracking of
zero this should be set to Optical as
well it is
perfect let's take this down to maybe
like 500 pixels
something like that you get the gist but
what's cool is all right so you lay out
everything and you lay it out in black
and white
now I have this plug-in from Overlord
let me pull that up real quick
the plugin is called Overlord
[Music]
but it's from a company called battle ax
and they make a few
uh they make rubber hose if you haven't
heard of them check them out they are
pretty cool make some awesome uh plugins
for
After Effects it is paid it's 45 but it
creates a tunnel between After Effects
and illustrator now again you do not
need this I just wanted to point out
that this was how I created all this
stuff and I wanted to Showcase how easy
Overlord is sometimes
instead of Designing frame by frame in
After Effects so it is a vector workflow
salvation and for the first time ever
text and gradient supported so that
means that I have two options in
illustrator let's actually jump over to
After Effects
let's create a new composition
call this grunge
typography
3840-2160 24 frames a second two seconds
long
we're only creating one still here and
the key with overload is you have to
have it open
in your extension in After Effects and I
have mine tucked away over here in the
corner
and you have to have it open
in illustrator as well
so
both places its window extension and
then Overlord and I have mine docked
because I use it all the time
but they just had to be open you don't
have to activate them or anything like
that and then what you can do is take
this and push your selection over to
After Effects let me turn off my
transparency and there you go exactly
how it shows up in illustrator it will
show up in After Effects
cool thing is is you can now still
[Music]
change this type if you want
you can go back
[Music]
whoops let's push this over again
I can right click here and go to create
shapes from text and now
I can delete my original text and now in
here I have contents and there's my
letter C my letter H all my different
letters so you can animate these
individually
if you know in illustrator that you are
set with this which is how I did my
original one here
you can make all of this typography once
you love your design
you can expand it so go to object expand
and you're going to create an object and
then fill that object
with the color that you have set up in
your original type so if this is red
it's going to fill it with red if it's
black white whatever your color is set
at the time that's what it's going to
fill
and now I can kick this over
and there you go it actually gives me
separate layers per letter and these are
shape layers
so
cool ways to work I just wanted to point
that out and you can either design in
After Effects or design an illustrator
but
I do love the capability of seeing all
my artboards in illustrator so that is
the route that I took
all right next video let's get to
designing
[Music]
[Music]